my inclination previously with all the
various books right for our work week
for our body for our Chef whatever it
might be I'm doing years of research
taking years of notes interviewing
dozens of experts and then come to my
conclusions and I say here are my
conclusions and what I've come to
believe at least with the long-form
audio format is I think it is more
helpful particularly with something like
mental health to share the process and
the struggles and some of the confusion
and the dead ends so that people not
only end up hopefully with something
they can use in the end but they don't
feel as alone in the struggle